what was the example we started with
first things assassin derivative of what
or cubed good now the reason why I had
to go this one was because specifically
you can do this without the chain rule
you don't need the chain rule for it
which is nice because there you can
verify that when you do the chain rule
you get the right answer which is what
we did and then you look at this there
is no expanding to do on this function
you can't expand that there's nothing to
expand if I were to write it in index
form by the way why would I write it in
x4 why is that instrumentally useful for
me because then I can use my my rule for
differentiating powers because it's an
index form so it would be this 25 minus
x squared serve are good once you do
that becomes clear there's no this is
not binomial theorem there's nothing to
expand here you're stuck now this
function is a semi-circle how do I know
it's a semi-circle apart from just
recognizing the form how would you be
able to convince someone this is a
semicircle actually got you here now
what would you suggest that's a good
argument we've got something that looks
very similar to a circle maybe that's
not quite as obvious to you so maybe off
on the side you want to write this with
me if this function were named why and
why was the square root of 25 minus x
squared then that square root sign
implies a restriction both on the range
and the domain I don't know why I said
in that order but anyway the domain
restriction means that you've got to
have X being between negative 5 and 5 do
you see that because if it were a big I
4 where I say 6 you'd have something
negative on the square root that's a
problem but in addition to having a
restriction on domain it restricts range
in what way
no matter what actually put in there by
definition which we love so very much
the square root is positive only right
so therefore well I should say it
includes zero you've got this range
restriction domain restriction this way
range restriction this way so now when
you square both sides keeping that
restriction in mind like that you can
see no he takes one more step to be able
to recognize oh yeah it's a circle
Center at the origin radius five does
that make sense but it's not the whole
circle there's a restriction so here is
my drawing okay
now I've picked this out so that we can
demonstrate if I wanted the gradient at
a particular point like say here this is
what am i drawing I'm drawing three
comma four okay how will I find it well
let's see how good you are at the chain
rule
what substitution should I introduce let
u equal that inside function there is 25
minus X square
having done that I could differentiate
with respect to X because that's that's
the variable in this function what is
that 25 give you nothing what is the
negative x squared give you negative 2x
so far so good now I've got to have the
Y on to you so I actually need to write
Y as a function of U well it's just that
you ^ 1/2 so what's my derivative with
respect to you bring that power out the
front and then reduce the power by 1 yep
okay so this is actually 1 on to root u
which is this do you agree now I can
combine them now I could do the chain in
chain rule I could say the actual
derivative that I'm after is let's have
a look here there's D or DX and
is dy or do you how you fairy so far and
you okay with the way that we strung
these together you can see I can do a
further bit of simplifying here and I
get this sorry X oops
that I canceled the with it okay now
before we move on and actually evaluate
this do you notice just look carefully
at this object before we move on the
denominator right what is the sine of
the denominator the sine of the
denominator must be positive all the
time
why is that it's because of this
restriction we were talking about before
right it's the square root must be
positive but this guy up here the sign
changes when X is negative that's on the
left hand side if X is negative what is
the sign of the numerator if X is
negative then it's a negative and a
negative so this is positive this is
positive but this is the gradient
function why does that make sense look
at the semicircle you see the semicircle
when X is negative on this side we'll
look it's increasing it's going up any
tangent you draw is going to be this
upward line does that make sense whereas
if you supply a positive value of x
that'll be negative
that'll be positive and that's why you
see all of these tangents will have a
negative gradient is that okay so you
can see here if I now evaluate the
gradient the gradient function at x
equals 3 can you tell me what we got to
get when x equals 3
tell me what's right there's the
numerator square root of 25 take away 9
so this is minus 3 on that's 16 isn't it
so this is negative 3/4 okay
and the reason why I highlight this is
because there's a really important
property that this tells us here's the
tangent we've just worked out that its
gradient is that so that's why it's
leaning down
that's the gradient of the tangent what
is the gradient of the nobel it's four
and three right four on three four on
three so in fact the normal in this case
it's not just any line it's the radius
and the radius keeps on going so in the
extension one course we all get to
circle geometry later but one of the
important properties is that the tangent
is perpendicular to the radius at the
point of contact and this is one of the
nice neat ways to actually prove that's
the case and it required chain rule okay